hey this is the cast of peacocks girls
bye bye
and of course our characters are friends
on screen
but we're also in love with each other
in real life irl so it's time to see
just how well we know each other let's
see
i love you oh my god is it me
yes
what's terrible about who's most doing
i'm just a little a little slow who's
most likely to respond in a group chat
wait which muppet is that paula you look
really hot today you need to get out
there and flirt yes for sure all day
every day
we're all good secret keepers good
secret keepers i don't agree that we're
all good too keepers i'm gonna take this
one i agree with this one you know some
of my secrets you're such a good friend
what do you want i've come from so far
are you making this about you i am it's
not fair renee lives literally tell him
you're a dress right now
we're not gone oh my god you would make
me i would talk to you i don't know any
tick tock dance no and i can't do it
because it's embarrassing
i mean me it's me guys come on god you
or you and paula and follow me depends
on if there's alcohol involved too well
there's bourbon
hey maybe
i think all of us give really good
advice
yeah yeah we crush
advice don't make me cry
me
for sure
okay there's age involved guys
there's a certain deterioration that
happens it's called your brain swiss
cheese in it
[Music]
you